si Genaro García Luna ha sido condenado
por los cinco cargos que se le acusaba
entre ellos el de pertenencia a una
empresa delictiva y también el de y
también de Conspiración para obtener
importar Y distribuir cocaína en Estados
Unidos además ha sido también condenado
por el delito de mentira a los
funcionarios públicos de inmigración
sobre su estatus legal en el 2018 hasta
el próximo 27 de junio no se conocerá la
sentencia a la que se enfrenta pero está
encima de la mesa la cadena perpetua a
pesar de todo el proceso García Luna se
sigue declarando Inocente de todos los
cargos que se le han acusado Y eso que
hemos escuchado durante al menos un mes
la declaración de 25 testigos que han
ido poco a poco pasando por el estrado y
demostrando poniendo encima de la mesa
pruebas que demostrarían la culpabilidad
de Genaro García Luna en estos delitos
entre ellos entre testigos que se han
escuchado muchos miembros pertenecientes
o ex miembros del Cartel De Sinaloa del
que precisamente su líder fue juzgado en
esa misma corte en la que ha sido
juzgado García Luna en la corte del
distrito este de Nueva York y
precisamente con el mismo juez fue
condenado a cadena perpetua en el 2019
estaríamos hablando de Joaquín Guzmán El
chapo como decía hasta el próximo 27 de
junio no conoceremos la sentencia en un
juicio en un proceso que ha sido seguido
por muchos medios nacionales pero
también internacionales porque no
olvidemos que se trata del exfuncionario
mexicano de mayor Rango que ha sido
condenado aquí en Estados Unidos